And then lastly, before we close out here, let's talk about how we might look at editing this in
Sequencer. So you can see that we've got our curve editor open in the top here. You can find your
curve editor by clicking this little curve button here. Maybe you want to maximize the window to see
all the curves. It's also worth noting you can save multiple editor layouts depending on the task.
So you could set up these windows for a certain type of task and then save a different layout
for maybe when you're editing content within an environment. So this is a setup that we'll use
to display the curves and also the Sequencer on the bottom. So essentially, Sequencer allows for
the trimming, editing, and manipulation of keyframes and animation curves captured with
Take Recorder. So anything from the virtual camera, which we saw an example of previously,
where we're using Live Link to capture virtual camera data, it moves to rig inversion animation
derived from recorded performance capture data. And then the performance capture takes the control
rig animations, the virtual camera movement, the live foley, and other Take Recorder assets
can all be edited and layered together in-engine with the use of the Sequencer tools such as
the Curve Editor. So we can really dial in from the captured performances exactly now what we want
to create almost like we're creating it in post, but we have access to all the preserved keys to
manipulate any content that we need to. And especially with all the recorded tracks that we
captured in the Take Recorder, we have access to all the extra data there. And then we can finalize
recordings in the Sequencer editorial tools. There's plenty of documentation on Sequencer
if you want to get familiar with how you might operate inside of Sequencer and how to set up
shots. But essentially, you can save the takes as a new level sequence, and then the level sequence
can be your sub-scene tracks. So we can set the camera binding ID in the camera cuts. So you can
see in the properties here, we can find the camera binding, we can create sub-scene tracks
in Sequencer, and we can add a V-cam track into the timeline and adjust the shot for a final edit.
You can either move around the shot durations in the timeline here, or you can even say about a
section, a range, end, and start. So plenty of options with Sequencer to really dial in the
performances that you've captured. And there's other courses recorded for you to look at with
Sequencer. And also you can find some great documentation.